hi I'm here in Davos and I heard an
amazing idea during the session of
captains Holly Berg who is via pilot who
landed the plane in the Hudson River he
had an amazing session yesterday packed
obviously and the amazing idea obviously
is to help you think ahead as you know
he's you know in aviation they say you
should always think ahead of the nose of
the plane and I think it applies to
business in an amazing way because you
if you run a start-up like I do you
always have to think about the next step
if you launch a product of course for
example you have to think about what's
going to happen next whether it fails or
whether it grows and how you manage it
and he was an amazing session because
for example he talked about how he had
130 page procedure butch at least but
you could have used any used somehow
ibiza co-pilot but if you think about it
they had three and a half minutes to
land the plane on the river and so he
cannot go for that so procedures are
needed but it's more like a feeling of
the fact that he could not land on an
alternate Airport that was around and
that he basically sided with experience
we reside that he could not make it and
went into the reverse saved 150
passengers and that made me think of us
that was a very powerful idea an amazing
novice moment